[Music]
force we hear the usage of this term
many times in our day-to-day life we
might not know that we're using it
opening a door riding a bicycle lifting
an object a few of the most common
things that we perform in our daily
lives and all these require a force what
is a force consider a ball lying on the
ground at rest it's not moving
suppose this player here wants to pass
this ball to his teammate who's standing
on the other side of the pitch how will
he do that he needs to make this ball
move in the direction of his teammate so
he will kick the ball in the direction
of his teammate when he kicks the ball
we say that he applied a force on the
football yes
the kick is nothing but the force he
applied on the ball now suppose that we
have a desk here at Point a a person
wants to move this desk from point A to
this point B again how will he do that
here he will push the desk towards point
B in this case we say that the person
applied a force on the desk in order to
shift it the bush here is the force that
the person applied on the desk similarly
when you lift some object from the table
we say that you applied a force on that
object here the force is applied in the
form of lifting so forces are nothing
but actions such as kicking pushing
lifting etc performed on objects there
are many such actions that we can
perform we have already seen few of
these some more of them are given below
while riding a bicycle we pedal it
continuously to keep it in motion here
pedaling is the force that we apply on a
bicycle
hitting the hammer on a nail is also a
force applied on the nail what about
stopping a moving ball yes even stopping
the ball means we are applying a force
on it we applied some force to stop the
ball opening a drawer plucking the
string of
Ghita moving a piece on a chessboard are
some of the other actions performed on
objects so performing these actions on
objects is nothing but applying force on
them but these are just a handful of
simply too many actions that we can
perform on the objects and it's not
possible to write each one of those but
we can categorize all these actions into
two basic ones that is we can describe
all these actions under two actions
namely pushing and pulling for example
when we open this drawer
we are simply pulling the knob of the
drawer to open it similarly when we are
drawing or lifting a bucket of water
from the well we are pulling the bucket
towards us what are the actions that can
be described under pushing actions such
as passing the ball hitting the hammer
on the nail etc can be thought of as
pushing an object
are there any actions that can be
described under both yes there are
suppose there's a book on the table you
can either pull it towards you like this
or push it away from you like this so
moving an object can be described under
both similarly opening or shutting a
door can be thought of as both so we
can't safely say at this point that the
forces are nothing but the push or pull
applied on objects forces are due to
interaction between the bodies or
objects what does it mean let's go back
to our first example of this video here
in order to pass the ball to his
teammate the player must move it that is
he must interact with the ball to move
it in the direction of his teammate he
interacts with the ball by kicking it
the ball and the player interact with
each other in the second example in
order to move the desk from point A to
point B he must interact with the desk
we will study more on these interactions
in the future videos now since we are
clear with the basic understanding of
what force is let me put its definition
in front of you it states that
force is a push or pull upon an object
resulting from the objects interaction
with another object in the next lesson
we will talk more about these
interactions see you then
[Music]